voici donc ma première question il
n'essaye pas de me rouler je te connais
comme si tu étais moi alors première
question est ce que tu préférerais être
un coq ou un âne un âne
j'adore les âmes et toutes les fois que
tu dis le moine je pense à cette
admirable poème de francis jammes prière
pour aller au paradis avec les âmes lane
c'est là martin c'est toute mon enfance
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus sexy en toi
ou qu'est ce qu'il y avait pas grand
chose peut-être mon regarde je crois pas
donc je crois pas être sexy du tout
qu'est ce qu'il y a de moins sexy en toi
mon ventre quelles choses négatives
dirais tu sur toi je dirais ce qu'on a
écrit sur mes bulletins scolaires aurait
pu faire mieux
as tu déjà pensé au suicide
oui et à quelles occasions à cause des
bonnes femmes sont des petits monstres
toujours les bonnes femmes
je prends sur suisse qui a tu le plus
envie d'épater la femme que j'aime
quel est pour toi le signe avant-coureur
de la passion naissante
qu'est ce qu'on appelle le signe
avant-coureur de la passion des cendres
c'est le désir ça se traduit comment
chez toi par un besoin d'en faire un peu
trop comme tous les hommes quand as-tu
pleurer pour la dernière fois il ya 300
pourquoi 34 ans toujours la même chose
toute façon au filet par s'y habituer à
quel signe reconnais tu infailliblement
la bêtise au fait qu'elle est appréciée
par le plus grand nombre
quelle est la dernière personne que tu
ais vu envie de tuer le maire de neuilly
quel est pour toi le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte au n'importe où en imagination
en vérité c'est beaucoup plus
confortable dans les arbres prévu pour
ça
le surnom comptes donne et que tu es
eh bien je ne suis jamais arrivé à
savoir je pense qu'on a mal fait gros
cul